is that ironic that before we're
watching him pretty much the only thing
I could remember was that there's a
speech about memory and I forgot the
rest
[Applause]
[Music]
all right folks rings of Akutan I really
had no idea what I was gonna get going
into this one it's one of those ones
that I like ivory washed maybe once but
it's been a long long time and I feel
like people have incredibly polarized
opinions on it I see it crop up in some
people's worst of lists but I see other
people highlight the doctor's speech
towards the end as one of the best
things ever so like this thing is all
over the map so and and that's always
been odd to me because I just didn't
really remember much of it it left very
little impression on me
as to be honest most of the Clara
episodes of series 7 do they the all of
these episodes and I'll try not to harp
on this each time but they're all a
little odd and a little off because
there's this background element of ooh
what's going on with Clara but that is
not in any way inter woven in the
episodes themselves so instead what we
have are a bunch of standalone episodes
with a character who does not yet have
an established rapport with the doctor
as part and without properly ceding any
kind of payoff for what we're supposed
to be finding out later the thing is and
this has actually kind of been
reiterated by how I think series 11
didn't particularly click well I think
for the first series with a new
companion you really kind of need to put
a heavy emphasis on that but most of
these stories are pretty just detached
and they don't weave one into the other
and they don't feel like they're doing
all that much to build up and establish
this relationship so we just have a
bunch of standalone stories that maybe
would have worked if we better
understood the the dynamic of the lead
characters but we don't yet because we
haven't had enough time with them
anyways that's a broad thing so coming
back to this the range of Akutan okay so
this is the one with the leaf and
there's the whole intro bit with Clara
and her parents meet because this leaf
blows into her father's face and her
mother pulls them out of the road and so
there's this idea that this leaf is the
entire reason that Clara was even born
which okay
and the doctor then you know takes her
on her first offworld adventure and they
go to the to Akutan and they have this
it's trying in some ways to be a little
bit like at the end of the world the
second episode of the first series where
we're gonna just bombard this new
command with a bunch of really bizarre
ian look at this and that and this and
so it's got that vibe a little bit then
we get then we get to what's going on
which is very weird and I don't know if
I'm going to explain it properly it's
one of those things that the idea is so
nuts that I feel like it should be
inherently more interesting to me than
it is because when Doctor Who goes
bonkers it doesn't always work but it
does tend to intrigue me a bit but here
for some reason it just doesn't
anyway you have this young girl who has
to sing this song it's this whole idea
of her taking you over the singing of
the long song to appease what she refers
to as grandfather and something goes
wrong and the girl effectively gets
yanked away to this temple the doctor
and Clara obviously go to try and rescue
her so then we've got this whole thing
of like well here's this thing in a cage
oh my I guess that's what she was
keeping asleep but now the songs over
it's awake oh wait that wasn't really
the thing it was the doctor says that
was its alarm clock which is that's a
really that's a really lame
justification for the fake out anyway
turns out it's this entire planet
so we now have a living planet that
feeds on stories sort of like it's
trying to absorb people's souls or their
memories or their stories but like it's
placated by the song because songs or
stories it I think this is a story that
would have worked really well either as
a novel or like us for issue comic
miniseries because these are ideas that
with more room to breathe than 45
minutes might have worked but I honestly
I don't even know if I'm describing it
accurately oh and also there's like
these weird almost faceless guys who are
like like enforcers but then they just
vanish so why were they there in the
first place
and I'd I don't I don't get what this
episode is trying to do I think that's
that's another part of the problem I can
pick out a bunch of thematic strands but
none of them seem to be the point and
there are times where theming can
bolster an episode a lot I think
the theming of depression does a lot to
bolster vision and the doctor not
everyone went with it but I think the
the theming also depression oddly enough
for can you hear me does a lot to
bolster that episode so you know there
are things that help bring these things
up but I can't tell you what the primary
theme of this actually is it's touching
on the value of memory it's touching on
the unfulfilled potential of anyone's
life it's touching on the idea of the
power of stories and they're all kind of
connected but it doesn't have a central
point it's making it doesn't have
something to actually connect these
themes and make them complement each
other they're just kind of there and
compounded by the fact that we still
don't really know Clara but
entire climax kind of banks's this idea
of the power of Clara or the cleverness
of Clara mm-hmm like yeah we need to
know who she is a bit more before you
can start banking on either paying off
ideas of her or subverting expectations
of her I don't have expectations yet you
can't subvert them I don't have them
again I don't even know if it's trying
to subvert expectations with what it's
doing it's uh there is a certain
cleverness to the idea of this thing
feeds off stories and the doctor is
saying you take mine take my memories
take my stories because obviously he has
more than most but the things not sated
and then what Clara offers him is the
potentially unlimited infinite stories
that didn't happen and the idea that
that is too much that's kind of a neat
idea but it doesn't it doesn't pull the
strands together and also I had to turn
like I remembered I hadn't backed right
I'd forgotten this was a problem but I'm
rewatching and I now remembered that
this was a problem for me I had to turn
on subtitles to understand what the hell
the doctor was even saying I don't know
if they had a new team doing the sound
mix at this point but he is being
drowned out during what is supposed to
be his big speech he is being drowned
out by the singing of other characters
the sort of noises of the planet which
also like the face on the planet is it's
not awful in itself but it's dumb how
quickly it shifts its it's like a it's
like watching an emoji change its if
that wasn't a great look but the sound
mix is is abysmal I can barely make out
anything that he's hearing which is
probably a big part of why first time I
saw this it didn't leave much of an
impression on me because I couldn't hear
him and I didn't think to have subtitles
on in advance this time you're watching
it I had to back it up and put subtitles
on you can't hear him I
oh man and like during the big climactic
speech thing
come on who I don't know who dropped the
ball on that but holy cow
but as frustrating as that was like I
don't I was gonna say I don't think it's
a bad episode I think it is but it's not
the kind of bad that like makes me angry
or annoys me
it's just bad because that didn't pull
together usually the things that really
get to me are bad because they betray
their own premise or the core idea
fundamentally I think is a bad idea to
begin with or it it has an element that
really gets me in the wrong way like I
actively hate the idiots Lantern for
multiple reasons because there are
things that I hate about it there's
nothing I hate about rings of Akutan
it's not good I'm not sure there's
anything much to salvage out of it even
that speech really it's it's a speech
that at the end of a more thematic ly
coherent episode might have pulled
everything together and capped it off
but as it stands it's just a very
committed performance from Matt Smith
that doesn't feel like it's paying
anything off properly
that's rings of Akutan it'll probably I
have a feeling my short-term memories
gonna fail to logon it's just gonna get
flushed away and be like oh yeah there
was some speech I don't remember
have you rewashed it lately what are
your thoughts on it whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it usual stuff like
subscribe I have a patreon so many
things to click but you also don't have
to because at the end of the day you're
at the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]